i i was a student not even a drama
student i was a law student
and uh we're taking a play to the
edinburgh festival which is this giant
arts festival in scotland thousands of
things go on
you can't get reviews because there's
thousands of things but you don't get an
audience without review so it's a
nightmare
and back in the day when i did when i
was young there were only two things
that reviewed you there was two
newspapers one
broadsheet one tabloid so we open at
lunchtime
it's this play you know there's a lot of
unity and swearing we thought was
brilliant we're students a lot you know
a lot of
like a lot of sex and stuff and
at midnight the broadsheet newspaper
came out and that first day we have five
people in the audience
we're six on stage five in the audience
and uh
midnight we're at this party where all
the performers used to go
and they would come in and dump the
newspapers in midnight everyone would
descend like vultures rip into pieces
see if they got a review but they're
only reviewing like 10 shows a day in
the thousands so you know
we wrote me we got a review first
day five percent we get a review and it
says
this is the worst piece of i've
ever seen in my life these people should
be shot
they're what gives student drama a bad
name avoid it like the plague
so we all think we've got the rest of
the summer doing the show
when we walk up onto this mountain in
the middle of bed and we're called off
the seat we take some tequila
probably some things that were illegal
at the time we sit up on the mountain
just so depressed we come down at five
o'clock in the morning
and outside uh a news agent but of
course you know a candy shop number is
um
piles of the tabloid newspaper the
shop's not open yet so they're sitting
there
on the street we grab one which was
still in the opening
and unbelievably we've been reviewed in
that too which means two of the five
people in the audience were reviewers
and it went this is the greatest thing
i've ever seen electrifying theater
pulls no punches
go and line up around the block with the
rest of us to watch these stars of
tomorrow
and we got both reviews we put them on a
poster we fly posted all over town where
these two people saw the same show
make your own mind up we sold out but it
was an early lesson
that none of it means none of it
it's somebody's opinion they want to
look
clever they've come up with a good pun a
bit of alliteration they don't care
about you and the work you've done they
just care about reading
their column you know so you shouldn't
look at it that's i don't know do you
have great stories